Welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. My name
is JD Quinn. I'm going to be your host.
I love this time because I love hearing
the answers along with you. Let me just
tell you real quick how we get the
answers. Then I'm going to introduce our
uh our people, our team, our panel, our
guest, you know, our family. And uh
number one, if you want to text your
question in, you can at
6182283975. If you'd like to email it
in, it's bible QA at
3ABN.tv. And if you like Instagram, it's
3ABN official. So now you know how to
get the questions to us and we look
forward to receiving them. And now let
me introduce our team here. We got
Pastor Johnny Deni. It's nice that
you're here, Johnny. Thank you. It's a
blessing to be here and I look forward
to uh answering the questions by the
grace of the Lord. We need the grace of
the Lord to be able to do this. Amen.
Pastor Daniel Morone. Thank you for
having me. Yes, I'm too thank you all
for sending your questions in that we
get to study and figure this out and
talk back to you guys. Sh. Amen. And my
precious wife, Shelley. Shelley Quinn.
It's a blessing to be here. We love you
and we thank you so much for
participating in this program. It gives
us the opportunity to do some serious
Bible study and I know that you do
serious Bible studies. I mean, this is
to me it's just amazing that you can sit
and you can study this out and condense
it into three or four minutes. We'll be
having 12 questions this uh today and
I'm looking forward to receiving them.
But let's go and let's have prayer
first. Okay. Father, as we come to you
in the name of Jesus, it's all about the
name of Jesus. And we thank you, Lord,
that we can call upon you at any time.
Father, be with us as we go through this
program. We just ask, Lord, that you
will through the aid of the Holy Spirit
just impress upon us what we need to do,
what we need to see, say, and Father, be
with each person that has ears to hear,
and eyes to see. We love you and we
thank you, and we ask this in the name
of Jesus. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Let's start off. Uh we have lots of
questions. Johnny, we're going to start
with you if that's
okay. First question. Why would Jesus
tell his disciples to tell no one that
he was Christ? I thought he wanted
everyone to know that he was the son of
God. Why would he keep that from
everyone? And this is from Shawn. Thank
you for that question. And we're going
to go ahead and go to the scripture that
is found in Matthew chapter 16, uh
beginning in verse 13. It says when
Jesus came into the region of Cesira,
Cesira Philippi or Philippi, he asked
his disciples saying, "Who do men say
that I, the son of man, am?" So they
said, "Some say John the Baptist, some
Elijah, and others Jeremiah or one of
the prophets." He said to them, "But who
do you say that I am?" Simon Peter
answered and said, "You are the Christ,
the Son of the living God." Jesus
answered and said to him, "Blessed are
you, Simon Barjonah, for flesh and blood
has not revealed this to you, but my
father who is in heaven." Notice that
Jesus did not deny that he was Jesus the
Christ, the Messiah that they were
waiting for. Now, let's jump to verse
20. Then Jesus commanded his disciples
that they should not tell no one that
they should tell no one that he was
Jesus the Christ. Now, why would Jesus
say that? And this is uh basically your
question. Didn't he want people to
know Jesus had a mission and he wanted
to bring the gospel to other people? But
if his fame spread abroad so much then
it would be difficult for him to
accomplish the things that he did.
Remember that the scribes and Pharisees
were constantly trying to trap him,
constantly trying to uh create problems
for him and hinder him from what he was
doing. So, it was best for that not to
spread like wildfire. But there was a
moment, notice one of the times that it
did occur in Mark chapter 1, beginning
in verse 40. I'll read quickly. Now, a
leper came to him imploring him,
kneeling down to him, and saying to him,
"If you are willing, you can make me
clean." Then Jesus moved with
compassion, stretched out his hand, and
touched him and said to him, "I am
willing, be cleansed." And as soon as he
had spoken, immediately the leprosy left
him, and he was cleansed. And he
strictly warned him, and sent him away
at once, and said to him, "See that you
say nothing to anyone, but go your way,
show yourself to the priest, and offer
for your cleansing those things which
Moses commanded as a testimony to them."
However, he went out and began to
proclaim it freely and to spread the
matter so that Jesus could no longer
openly enter the city but what's outside
in deserted places and they came to him
from every direction. So you see it
would have slowed down the work that he
had to do. It would have hindered him
from going to as many places as he
needed to go. And so this was one of the
reasons why he did so. And of course the
scribes and Pharisees by that time they
were looking for Jesus. They were they
already wanted to put him to death. And
so Jesus wanted to accomplish all that
he wanted to accomplish before he gave
up his life to die for us. So uh this is
one of the reasons and I encourage you
to continue studying God's word. Amen.
Thank you Johnny Daniel. What is the
meaning of casting lots? Is it a
practice in Christianity today or should
it be practiced? This is from Omar.
Omar, thank you so much for that
question. Let me just read a few of
those texts that you're talking about
where it talks about
uh drawing lots or getting the small
straw. Amen. Short straw. Leviticus.
Yeah. Leviticus 16:8. And Aaron shall
cast lots upon the two goats, one lot
for the Lord and the other lot for the
scapegoat. In Joshua 18:6 it says, "Ye
shall therefore describe the land into
seven parts and bring the description
hither to me that I may cast lots for
you here before the Lord our God." Then
in 1st Samuel 14:42, "And Saul said,
cast lots between me and Jonathan, my
son." And Jonathan was taken. There's
actually about 19 verses that talks
about casting lots. Psalm
22:18 it says, "They part my garments
among them and cast lots upon my
vesture." Then in the New Testament,
that was fulfilled. Matthew 27:35, "And
they crucified him and parted his
garments, casting lots, that it might be
fulfilled which was spoken by the
prophet, that they parted my garments
among them, and upon my vesture did they
cast lots." So we have one example of
the church in the New Testament casting
lots. I mean beside that one where it
was actually um after Pentecost was well
around that time. Acts chapter 1 23-26.
And they appointed to Joseph called
Barabus who was surnamed justice and
Matias. And they prayed and said thou
Lord which knowest the hearts of all
men. Show whether of these two thou hast
chosen, that he may take part of the
ministry and apostilhip from which Judas
by transgression fell, that he might go
to his own place. And they gave forth
their lots. And the lot fell upon
Matias, and he was numbered with the 11
apostles. So it was understood actually
back then that the Lord had the final
control of who got what lot. Proverbs
16:33 says that the lot is cast into the
lap, but the whole disposing thereof is
of the Lord. So it's interesting to note
that after Pentecost, the direct
guidance of the Holy Spirit made the
casting of lots superfluous or
unnecessary.
In Acts 5:3 it says, "But Peter said,
Ananas, why hath Satan filled thine
heart to lie to the Holy Ghost and to
keep back part of the price of the
land?" Then in Acts
13:2, as they ministered to the Lord and
fasted, the Holy Ghost said, "Separate
me Barnabas and Saul for the work where
I have called them." So, thank you again
for that question. And it seems like we
should just listen to the Holy Spirit
nowadays. Amen. Amen. Very
good. Shelley, your first question. How
do we know the Earth is around 6,000
years old when science says otherwise
with the evidence of fossils, etc. And
this is from Jack. So, how do we know
how old the Earth is? Jack, I love this
question because I used to have it
myself. If we think about
creation, God created the earth with
apparent age. What I mean is Adam and
Eve were fully mature adults. Animals
were mature. Everybody was ready to go
forth and multiply according to God's
commands. The trees were fully grown and
bearing fruit. So basically scientists
cannot determine the age of the earth by
human reasoning or by flawed dating
methods. Scientists estimate this is
interesting that the earth is 4.5
billion years old. This contradicts
God's word and it changes all the time.
The biblical world view, biblical world
view, I'll say that right. Biblical
chronology shows us that the earth is
around 6,000 years. The Old Testament
covers 4,000 years of history. The New
Testament 100 years of the of Christian
history. And then we know that Christ
came of it's been 2,000 years since his
death. So this would be 6,000 years. In
Genesis 1, the creation account, the
Hebrew word when it says, "And the
evening and the morning were the first
day, the evening and the morning were
the second day." The word used for day
is yam. And when it's used with evening
and morning as that, it consistently
means a literal
24hour period of scripture. And Exodus
20:1 confirms that God created the earth
in 6 days. So Genesis and the biblical
genealogies, Jesus teachings, and the
impact of the global flood let us know
the earth is 6,000 years. Jesus
referenced Adam and Eve as historical
figures in Matthew 19:es 4 and 6. Luke's
genealogy traces gene Jesus lineage all
the way back to Adam, the son of God, as
he's called in Luke 3:38. So if Adam was
created billions of years ago after the
earth was formed, then the whole
biblical timeline would collapse. Romans
5:12 tells us sin entered through that
one man, Adam, causing death. And that
implies there was no
sin before Adam's sin. So that
contradicts evolution. The worldwide
flood in Genesis chapter
6-9
significantly altered Earth's geology
which affected the dating methods. The
flood model according to the Bible
explains that there were cataclysmic
geological shifts with this worldwide
flood that caused rapid burial of
organisms forming fossils much faster
than conventional models suggest and we
find them in the same layers all around
the world.
So science assumes that there was a
gradual change and they use the geologic
column, fossil record and radiometric
dating methods that rely on assumptions
about decay rates and moral conditions.
But if you look at say for example
alternate methods like the carbon dating
method carbon 14 that's found in ancient
fossils we see that the ear world is a
lot younger and bottom line science and
faith should align but when they appear
to conflict take scripture as final
authority. Amen. Well explained. Uh
Johnny number two, in the parable Jesus
told in Matthew 22 about the wedding
feast, he mentioned a man who came in
without a wedding garment. Since the man
did not have on the wedding garment, how
did he get inside in the first place? If
the wedding garment was an obvious
requirement, this is from Bernard in
Jamaica. His question is, can you please
explain the parable of the wedding feast
in Matthew 22?
Thank you very much. A good question.
And so this this is an interesting
question because
um in this parable that Jesus told he is
letting us know that there is a
requirement to enter into the wedding
feast of God's son and that is to wear
the wedding garment. What is this
wedding garment? The wedding garment is
the righteousness of Jesus Christ. Mhm.
And to be able to enter in, you must
have that wedding garment. In this
story, in this parable that Jesus told,
uh, the invitation goes out to those
that were invited to the feast, but they
made excuse. Oh, I have to do this, I
have to do that. And no, none of the
people invited were willing to ex to
come to the wedding feast. I go now to
Matthew 22:es 8-10. Notice what the
Bible says. Then he said to his
servants, "Servants, the wedding is
ready, but those who were invited were
not worthy. Therefore, go into the
highways, and as many as you find invite
to the wedding, no one will go to heaven
uh forcefully, it's an invitation." And
that's why uh you you see the scriptures
that says John 3:16, for God so loved
the world that whosoever believes in him
shall not perish but have everlasting
life. It's an invitation that God makes
to people. And so we continue there. Um
as many as you find. So those servants
went out into the highways and gathered
together all whom they found both bad
and good. And the wedding was filled
with guests. And so as you said, verse
11, but when the king came in to see the
guests, he saw a man there who did not
have on a wedding garment. He said, so
he said to him, "Friend, how did you
come in here without a wedding garment,
and he was speechless?" In other words,
he could not explain. Now, why didn't he
have on the wedding garment? It was
provided freely. And so, the Bible does
not tell us how this man got in there.
The fact is that he got in. We have to
look at the important elements of the
parable in order to understand that
nobody really is going to be allowed to
be there that is not supposed to be
there. Even though the invitation is
made and everything is provided
including the righteousness of Christ,
you must accept the righteousness of
Christ. You cannot get in there with
your own righteousness. Our
righteousness are as filthy rags. And so
we we can only get in there through
Jesus Christ. There is no other way.
Jesus is the way, the truth, and the
life. Notice what happens to this man in
Matthew 22 uh verse 13. Then the king
said to his servants, "Bind him hand and
foot, take him away, and cast him into
utter darkness. There will be weeping
and nashing of teeth." Now, why was this
man cast into utter darkness? Did he not
say, "Bring in as many as uh you find."
Now, why was he not permitted? because
the requirements are for us to have the
righteousness of Christ. Amen. Amen.
Daniel number two. Were the crusades of
the Middle Ages specifically for the
eradication of Sabbathke keepers? And
this is from Linda in Vermont.
Well, thank you, Linda. Well, the short
answer is actually no. That wasn't what
the main reason was. So the crusades
were organized by Western European
Christians after centuries of Muslim
wars of expansion. The Muslim war was
growing. So their primary objectives
were to stop the expansion of the Muslim
states to reclaim for Christianity the
Holy Land in the Middle East and to
recapture territories that were formerly
Christian. Some of the long-term results
of the crusades were that they slowed
the advanced Islamic power and may have
prevented Western Europe from falling
under Muslim control and Constantinople
never returned to its former glory after
being sacked by the fourth
crusade and a schism between the Eastern
and Roman Catholic Christianity was
further entrenched. So the Islamic world
saw the crusaders as cruel invaders
which helped engender distrust and
resentment toward the Christian world.
Still going on today, isn't it? The word
crusade comes from the Latin word crux
and means cross. The Christian soldiers
called crusaders wore the cross as a
symbol of their religion. So they call
it a holy war. And the crusades were a
series of wars between European
Christians and Muslims. and they took
place between 1095 and 1291. As far as
the Sabbath goes, there was actually a
lot of suppression of the Sabbath in the
early Christian uh realm. When the
emperor of Rome, Constantine, he became
a Christian, he made the first law
concerning Sunday as a day of rest and
later it becoming a day of worship. So
it's true that western Christian church
used the term crusade for other
credences or beliefs that the church
considered heretical and the seventh day
Sabbath was definitely one of them.
Other Christians believe that there were
two gods. One over the material world
and the other over spiritual realm. So
they tried to stamp that out. Crusades
continued for several centuries after
1291.
uh crusading declined rapidly during the
16th century with the advent of the
Protestant Reformation and then the
decline of papal authority. Thank you
again for that question. Wow, very
interesting. That is interesting,
Shellyley. Yes, sir. Second question.
What happens to the unrighteous who are
alive at the time of rapture when
believers are caught up in the air to
meet Jesus Christ? Do they stay here on
earth during the millennium? Does God
judge them during the Does God judge
them during the millennium in the light
of Revelation 20? And this is from Dan
in South Africa. Dan, this is a question
on a lot of people's minds. I hope you
have a pen and paper. I'm going to give
you a number of scriptures very rapidly.
In John
5:28-29, Jesus refers to two
resurrections. Though those who have
done good come up to resurrection of
life, those who have done evil to the
resurrection of condemnation. In first
Thessalonians
4:15-17, we see that those who are
asleep in their grave at his second
coming. They come up first and then the
righteous are caught up with them
together in the air to meet Christ. In 1
Corinthians
15:51-54, we see that Christ has
returned for his covenant people, at
which time he closed them with
immortality. And then Revelation
25-6 explains that the righteous go to
heaven, reign with Christ for a thousand
years, uh, and the second death has no
power over the righteous is what
Revelation 25 and6 says.
Now in in Revelation 25 it says that the
second resurrection is after the
thousand years. It is after the
millennium because see 2 Corinthians
write these down. 2 Corinthians 1:es
7-10 and excuse me 2
Thessalonians 1 7-10 and 2 Thessalonians
2 verse8 Paul tells us that the light of
Christ's countenance will consume evil
he says in flaming fire as he takes
quote vengeance on those who do not know
God and on those who do not obey unquote
Then he says he consumes them with the
breath of his mouth and devours them
with the brightness of his coming. So
when Christ returns the wicked will be
destroyed. There is no second chance for
the wicked. You know just as God closed
the door to the ark. I mean he had Noah
appreach for 120 years but he closed the
ark. And this is what's going to happen
just like after the or the flood time
when Christ returns the the door of
salvation is closed. No one will be um
able to enter the kingdom after that. So
the wicked lie on earth during that
thousand years. They're dead. Jeremiah
4:23 says, "I beheld the earth and it
was without form and void." And at the
end of the thousand years, they're
resurrected in the second resurrection
of condemnation. And they are
condemned and and given a final
execution, the God's righteous justice,
condemned sin at the white throne
judgment, and they're thrown into the
lake of fire to utterly perish. Let me
read this to you quickly. Revelation
20:es
11-15. I saw a great white throne and
him who sat on it, from whose face the
earth and the heaven fled away, and
there was found no place for them. I saw
the dead, small and great. This isn't
the righteous, this is the evil,
standing before God, and books were
open, and another book was open, which
is the book of life. And the dead were
judged according to their works by the
things which in the were in the books.
The sea gave up the dead and those who
were in it. Death and Hades delivered up
the dead who were in them. And they were
judged, each one according to his works.
Then death and Hades were cast into the
lake of fire. This is the second death.
It says, "And anyone not found in the
book of life was cast into the lake of
fire." are the cowardly, unbelieving,
abominable, murderers, sexually immoral,
sorcerers, idolattors, and all liars
shall have their part in the lake which
burns with fire and brimstone, which is
the second death. Amen. Well presented,
Shelley. Just want to take a couple of
seconds here and let you know how much
we appreciate your questions. But if you
don't know how to contact us, let me
give you three ways of doing that to
send the questions in. Number one is if
you choose to text, well, it's
2283975.
618-228-3975 perhaps uh email that's
bible
qa3abn.tv biblea
3abn.tv. And the third one is Instagram
3ABN_official. We look forward to
getting your questions and we appreciate
it so much. Johnny, let's pick up now on
your third
question. If I read or hear a prayer
that I like, is it okay to write it down
and use it? And this is from Devana in
Texas.
Thank you, Dana, for that question. And
uh we encourage everyone to keep sending
in your questions. Uh, I would like to
tell you that there's no scripture that
appears to prevent that or prohibit
that. But I would, uh, encourage you to
consider that we need to be careful with
this because we need to really make it
our own and approach God in sincerity.
I'm not saying that you won't do that in
sincerity. Uh, if the prayer inspires
you and you would like to use those
words, but bring it to the Lord from
your heart. And there are some things
that Jesus says concerning prayer and I
would like to point those to you.
Matthew chapter 6 and I would like to
begin in verse 5. Notice what Jesus says
uh to the people concerning prayer. When
you pray you shall not be like the
hypocrites for they love to pray
standing in the synagogues and on the
corners of the streets that they may be
seen by men. Assur surely I say to you
they have their reward. But when you
pray go into your room and in some
versions say your closet. And when you
have shut your door, pray to your father
who is in secret. And your father who
sees in secret will reward you openly.
And when you pray, notice, do not use
vain repetitions as the heathens do. For
they think they will be heard for their
many words. So sometimes people think if
they give flowery words and flowery
speeches that will commend them to God.
But we need to just come to God with
sincerity of heart in humility
presenting a request from the the depths
of our heart, the depths of our soul. Uh
Mark chapter 7 verse 6 says concerning
some people uh that Jesus noticed this
about them when it says he answered and
said to them well did Isaiah prophesy of
you hypocrites as it is written this
people honors me with their lips but
their heart is far from me. So I'm not
saying you're a hypocrite. I'm just
saying that when Jesus is talking about
we need to come to him from the heart
the the these people were just saying
praise the Lord we honor you we praise
you and but they were not putting their
heart into it let us put our heart into
the prayers we present to the lord speak
to him as our heavenly father and this
is why it's wonderful the way Jesus
presents to us when you pray say our
father which is in heaven He is
approachable. We can approach the Lord
because he considers us his children.
Philippians chapter 4 um verse six. Be
anxious for nothing but in everything by
prayer and supplication with
thanksgiving. Let your request be made
known to God. So come to the Lord, pour
out your heart before him in sincerity
of heart and he will hear you. He loves
you and wants to hear from you. and uh
take time to get to know your heavenly
father. Amen. Thank you, Johnny.
Daniel, how does the church approach and
support individuals who are intersects,
meaning that they have both male and
female biological
characteristics? How can we ensure they
feel welcomed and valued in the church
community? This is from Norin.
That's a good question. Sensitive
question there, Norin. appreciate your
sensitivity. And yes, it is called
interex. And it's quite rare actually.
One in,500 to 2,000 births that a child
can be born with both male and female
organs. If I'm hearing you correctly,
Norine, I am sensing your
uncomfortableness, which is what I want
to address in my answer. I recall when I
was in my second year of nursing at
Pacific Union College, we were in our
psych rotation and our professor wanted
us to experience what it feels like
being on the other side of someone with
a disability. I was partnered up with
Marilyn Ketzner. She was a another
student in our class. We chose to be in
a wheelchair, which was rarer back then
being in a wheelchair. But uh I pushed
Marilyn up and down on Glendale
Adventist or Glendale Boulevard for
about an hour or two and she was engaged
to Ed Wright. So she wanted to browse
stores that had things she might want in
their new home. I recall watching people
looking from far away, but then when we
got closer they would quickly look away.
When it came my turn to be pushed in the
wheelchair, I decided to sit on one of
my legs and I had a lap blanket over me.
So, it appeared that I was an
amputee. And I experienced this staring
looking at me from far away, you know,
and then you look up and the people
turned their eyes away when we got
closer. And the thing that I will always
remember about this
experience and by the way they wanted us
nurses to be able to sympathize or
empathize with our uh patients that we
took care
of. Um this the thing that I remember
was I wanted to buy Marilyn an ice cream
cone. So we went into this ice cream
soda soda fountain and the attendant he
wouldn't look at me and I was talking
directly to him and I was the guy
paying. So that was just I thought whoa
we what's going on here? It made me
really feel
uncomfortable because he felt
uncomfortable.
So that his uncomfortable made me
uncomfortableness. So I say all of that
to say that in dealing with a person or
anyone that has something that makes you
feel uncomfortable, think of that person
and try to make them feel as normal as
possible. You know, I I would start by
introducing myself to the person and ask
them for their name. So then you can
call them by their
name and then just call Yeah. And then
ask them about hobbies or work, things
that are neutral, you know, things that
you're you're comfortable with, their
hobbies, their work, or do they have
siblings? Are their parents alive, etc.
And hopefully this will get you started.
And of course, always pray and ask the
Lord while you're conversing with
somebody, just helping them to feel
comfortable. Thank you for the question.
Huh. Great answer. Wow. It was good.
Help us
Jesus. Shelley, how many Marys are there
in the Bible? And this is from Mar from
Mary in Oregon.
Mary, there are definitely at least
four. Some people say there are five or
six. Let's look at it. First, there's
Mary, the mother of Jesus. She's
identified six times with certainty in
scripture and there's possibly another
three references. She is it's mostly
talking about her u she's the virgin
that was given uh chosen to give birth
to the person of Jesus Christ. She was
present at his crucifixion and his
resurrection. And the last time that she
is mentioned in the Bible is in the
upper room on the day of Pentecost.
Scripture does not venerate Mary, but it
presents her as a virtuous woman.
Matthew
12:48-50. When Jesus was told that his
mother and brothers were outside
seeking, he responded saying, "Who's my
mother and my brothers?" And then
stretching out his hands toward his
disciples, he said, "Here are my mother
and my brothers. For whoever does the
will of my father in heaven is my
brother and sister and mother. Now
that's the first Mary. Then there's Mary
Magdalene. Luke 8:2. She's a devoted
follower of Jesus from whom were cast
out seven demons. John 20 11 through18.
She's the first to see the resurrected
Christ. So there's the Mary of Bethany.
Luke
10:38-42. She's a sister of Martha and
Lazarus. She's known for sitting at
Jesus' feet and anointing him with
perfume. John 12
1-3. My personal Bible study, I believe
Mary Magdalene and Mary of Bethany are
one and the same. And I've done
extensive study on this. There is Mary,
the mother of James and Joseph or
Joseph. She was present at Christ's
crucifixion. We see that and his
resurrection in Matthew
27:56, Mark 15:40 and 16:1. Mary the
wife of Kloppus is mentioned in John
19:25 is standing near the cross of
Jesus. And many scholars believe that
Mary the mother of James and Joseph and
is the wife of Clapus. So that at that
point would make us with three. Then
there's Mary the mother of John Mark. We
see in Acts 12:12 she was an uh a
Christian early Christian. She opened
her home uh for believers. She hosted
believers in her home.
And this included Peter if you remember
after his miraculous release from
prison. So the so four Marys at least
perhaps six each Mary played a
significant role in Bible history
especially in Jesus ministry death and
resurrection.
Amen. Amen.
Johnny your last question. Yes sir. My
friend is converting to Adventism, but
previously believed in speaking in
tongues. What scripture can I share to
help her understand that speaking in
tonesues isn't necessary to communicate
with God? And this is from Barbara in
New York.
Thank you, Barbara. I see your concern
for your friend. Um, when we look in the
scriptures, we see in Acts chapter 2 the
true manifestation of the gift of
tongues. Um, I'm going to go ahead and
read some of these verses here. Acts
chapter 2 and beginning in verse 7.
Notice this says, "Then they were all
amazed and marveled, saying to one
another, look, are not all these who
speak Galileans? How is it that we hear
each in our own language in which we
were born? And then it lists some of
these languages. I'll just read one
verse. Parththeians and me, Elommites,
those dwelling in Mesopotamia, Judea,
Capidoshia, Pontius, and Asia. And it
continues uh naming these. And verse 11
says, "Cretins and Arabs. We hear them
speaking in our own tongues the
wonderful works of God." In other words,
these people were understanding what
these uh apostles, these disciples of
the Lord were saying. So the true
manifestation of the gift of tongues is
a language that is known in the world.
And so these disciples that did not
speak these languages uh were blessed
with the gift to speak in other
languages for what purpose? For the
edifying of God's people. To bring a
blessing to God's people. What did they
hear? The wonderful works of God. This
is the true manifestation of the gift of
tongues. In 1 Corinthians chapter 14,
there we see some things that Paul is
saying to the Corinthians. It appears
that there may have been some extremes
in this. And the people for some reason
uh they all wanted to speak in these
other languages, but Paul is bringing
some information to bring things to
order. And so let's go ahead and uh I
think I have to begin in verse nine for
the sake of time. Paul says, "So
likewise you unless you utter by the
tongue words easy to understand, how
will it be known what is spoken? For you
will be speaking into the air." So the
idea of speaking in a language that is
not known under heaven. Um then you're
speaking to the air. Your understanding
is your your words are not beneficial to
anyone that hears you and not even to
yourself. Uh notice some of the things
presented here. There are it may be so
many kinds of languages in the world and
none of them is without significance.
They all have some meaning. Paul is
saying therefore I do not know therefore
if I do not know the meaning of the
language I shall be a foreigner to him
who speaks and he who speaks will be a
foreigner to me. We're not going to be
able to communicate. We're not going to
be able to understand each other. Even
so, since you are zealous for spiritual
gifts, let it be for the edification of
the church that you seek to excel. Every
gift that God gives is for edification,
for the benefit of God's people in
general. Therefore, let him who speaks
in a tongue pray that he may interpret.
So, if there's no interpretation, what
are you supposed to do? Keep silent.
This is what Paul says. Notice what it
says. For if I pray in a tongue, my
spirit prays, but my understanding is
unfruitful. So here's the conclusion in
verse 15. Paul says, what is the
conclusion then? I will pray with the
spirit and I will also pray with the
understanding. I will sing with the
spirit and I will also sing with the
understanding. So this is something to
be able to share with your friend. when
you sing, when you pray, you have to
pray with understanding because that is
an expression of what's in your heart to
God if you are praying to the Lord. Uh
so unfortunately uh there are some
extreme extremes in this and
unfortunately there are some people that
are saying they're speaking in tongues
in an unknown language but it's really
unknown to the people around them and it
may be that it's also unknown to God
because it's not they're not really
words. So let us come to the Lord with
sincerity of heart as I said earlier and
let us speak to him from our heart and
he will listen attentively because he
wants to hear from each and every one of
us. Amen. Amen. Thank you. Very well
explained.
Daniel, was Elijah taken to heaven?
Later he is still seen during the reign
of King Jehoakan.
Well, that's a good question there,
Luda. Thank you so much for sending that
in. Let me just read about Elijah going
to heaven for our audience. 2 Kings
chapter 2:1. And it came to pass when
the Lord would take up Elijah into
heaven by a whirlwind that Elijah went
with Elisha from
Gilgal. Later in verse 11, it says, "And
it came to pass as they still went on
and talked that behold there appeared a
chariot of fire and horses of fire and
parted them both aunderder. And Elijah
went up by a whirlwind into heaven. You
know, we had a uh person watching one of
our programs and they heard us say that
Elijah went to heaven in a chariot of
fire. But the text actually says that
this chariot and horse of fire just
separated Elijah and Elisha and that
they went up to heaven via a whirlwind.
So we want to thank you. You know, we
know that there's a lot of scholars out
there watching us. So if you see us say
something wrong, let us know. Write to
us. In fact, I just got one this last
week. Fella, I explained about December
25 and he wanted to update me on what
the latest things were about Christmas
becoming December 25. So, we appreciate
you guys letting us know being part of
our study here. So, regarding Elijah and
him being uh around when Jehoakim
reigned in Judah, you know, I wasn't
actually able to find this. Uh so, Luda,
if if you find it, give me the text
where that says that. But Jehoakim
reigned from 608 BC to 598 BC. And
Elijah was a prominent prophet during
the reign of King Ahab in the northern
kingdom of Israel. Ahab reigned from 874
to 853 BC. This was about a 245 year
spread between these two kings.
So, I took the liberty to look into the
possibility that you may have actually
been thinking of King Jihoram of Judah.
After all, with so many of these kings
starting with the letter J, it's easy
for me to get them mixed up. It was
during the reign of Jihoream over Israel
that Jehoshaphat's son, who was also
named Jihoream. That's interesting,
isn't it? The northern kingdom had a
Jihoream and then the southern kingdom
had a Jehoram at the same time. Well, he
ascended the throne of Judah. So, he
married the daughter of King Ahab and
Queen Jezebel. He was doing all kinds of
wicked things. We see that in 2
Chronicles 21:6. It's and quote, "He
walked in the ways of the kings of
Israel, like as did the house of Ahab.
For he had the daughter of Ahab to wife,
and he wrought that which was evil in
the eyes of the Lord."
So even though Elijah was a prophet from
the north in Israel, he had heard about
what this king was doing and the Lord
gave him this message of rebuke. And
then so Elijah actually wrote a letter
to Jehoram. And we see that in 2 Coron 2
Chronicles 21 and verse 12. And there
came a writing to him that was to
Jehoram from Elijah the prophet saying,
"Thus sayaeth the Lord God of David thy
father, because thou hast not walked in
the ways of Jehoshaphat thy father, nor
in the way ways of Asa, king of Judah,
the" and then the rest of the chapter
goes into all the punishment that he was
going to receive because of the evil
things that he was doing.
So just because um 2 Chronicles follows
2 Kings in the Bible where it's talking
about Elijah going up in 2 Kings uh it's
not necessarily chronological in the
Bible if that makes any sense. In other
words, Elijah was still alive and around
when this was happening. He hadn't yet
ascended to heaven. So I hope that
helped you there. Again, thank you so
much. Uh Luda from Kenya. Appreciate
you. Thank you. Thank you, Shelley. Your
fourth question. Can you please explain
2 Corinthians 12
1-6? Is Paul having a vision of
paradise? Do the men mentioned in verses
2 and three happen in real life? Who are
these men? And this is from Joseph in
Arizona. Joseph, I hope you have your
Bible open to second Corinthians chapter
12. We're going to walk through this
verse by
verse in well close to that 2
Corinthians 12 1-6. Paul says, "It is
doubtless not profitable for me to
boast. I will come to visions and
revelations of the Lord." So he's
reluctant to boast. He recognizes
there's no spiritual benefit in
boasting, but he's compelled to mention
a vision experience that he himself had.
We find that out in verse 7, uh, that
God had given him this vision because
Paul says that he's forced to defend his
apostilhip. Verse 11, he says, "I've
become a fool in boasting, but you've
compelled me." So we know in context
this is Paul speaking of himself. Verse
two Corinthians 12:e 2. I know a man in
Christ who 14 years ago whether in the
body or out of the body I do not know.
God knows such a one was caught up to
the third heaven. And I know such a man
whether in the body or out of the body I
do not know. God knows. but how he was
caught up into parab paradise and heard
inexpressable words which is not lawful
for a man to utter. So Paul is here
referring to himself in the third person
to avoid sounding prideful. The third
heaven is God's dwelling place. The
first heaven is the earth's atmosphere.
The second heaven is the outer space.
The third heaven was God's dwelling
place. So this vision was so
overwhelmingly realistic. Paul wasn't
sure if he was physically taken up to
heaven or if it was purely a spiritual
experience. He says in verse 5, "Of such
a one I will not boast. Yet of myself I
will or he says of such a one I will
boast. Yet of myself I will not boast
except in my infirmities. For though I
might desire to boast, I will not be a
fool. For I will speak the truth, but I
refrain lest anyone should think of me
above what he sees me to be or hears
from me. Here's the greatest part. Now,
we're going to jump down to verse 7. 2
Corinthians 12:7. Lest I should be
exalted above measure by the abundance
of the revelations. So once again, we
know he received that a thorn of my
flesh was given to me, a messenger of
Satan to buffet me, lest I be exalted
above measure. And concerning this
thing, I pleaded with the Lord three
times that it might depart from me. And
he said, verse 12, "My grace is
sufficient for you, for my strength is
made perfect in weakness. Therefore,
most gladly I will boast in my
infirmities that the power of Christ may
rest upon me. Here's the bottom line.
Paul wasn't exalting self. Paul's
Paul's I think Paul's strength was his
humility. He was the one who said, "I
die daily, brothers."
Paul knew that he, as a matter of fact,
he goes on and he says, "I I welcome
these infirmities because when I am
weak, then I am strong because Christ's
power rests on me." So, here's what I
take from this. Paul wants us to know
there's no spiritual benefit in
boasting. And for a leader, no leader
should take the glory of God. It should
be passed on to God. And every leader
should be dependent upon the Lord and
passing the glory on, pointing us to
Jesus, passing that glory on rather than
trying to seek glory for themselves.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Do you all have anything that you might
want to add to one of your responses?
Yes, actually in this in this aspect of
coming to the Lord in prayer, you know,
uh we had a a message from Dvana about
if I hear a prayer that I like, can I
write it down and use it? You know, the
Lord is very interested in us
approaching him and coming to him. I
want to point to you to Hebrews chapter
4 uh beginning uh verse 15 and 16. For
we do not have a high priest which who
cannot sympathize with our weaknesses
but was in all points tempted as we are
yet without sin. Considering this, it
says, let us therefore come boldly to
the throne of grace that we may obtain
mercy and find grace to help in time of
need. It would be beneficial and a great
blessing for each and every one of us to
spend more time in prayer to the Lord,
pouring our hearts before him and
seeking to know him better by the study
of his word. So I want to encourage you
to do that. You know, there are times I
I was reading the other day, I looked up
the words, tie him thine, O Lord, you
know, draw me near and near. Fanny
Crosby wrote this and it's interesting
sometimes because really that's a song
that's a prayer that's set to music.
There are times you can read something
and the words how the spirit moved Fanny
Crosby to read. It can touch your heart.
I I was crying. I mean I was just
weeping and it was like it was such a
surprise to me.
But God wants us, he is our aba father.
That's a very intimate term. And he does
want us to pray to him just like a a
little child would talk to his father.
We don't have to be fancy. But I do
understand there are times some prayers
are really good to touch your heart.
Well, listen, why don't we take a
temporary break? We'll come back with
some uh contacts and uh then we'll share
some more final thoughts. Okay. Amen.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's bibleqa
at3abn.tv. You may also text your
questions to
6182283975. That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live. And then watch
through Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word. Welcome back. Uh, do we have any
additional comments or final thoughts?
We've got probably a minute and a half.
I'm just thinking about Dan in South
Africa who is asking what happens to the
unrighteous after Christ's return. And I
I wanted to add this. I grew up for uh
for 48 years. I believed that the Lord
was a God who was going to burn us
forever. And that didn't make any sense
to me. And I kept him at arms length.
But when I really started studying this
scripture, the second death is mentioned
four times in
Revelation. Look those scriptures up
because God, Jesus himself said that God
so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever would
believe in
him would not perish but have
everlasting life. The juxiposition
perish meant to be utterly destroyed.
God is a loving God and he's not going
to burn every anyone forever. Amen.
Amen. Powerful. Anybody else? Uh yes.
Matthew 11 24 Jesus says to us,
"Therefore I say to you, whatever things
you ask when you pray, believe that you
receive them and you will have them."
You know uh let us ask the Lord
believing when we come to the Lord and
believe that he wants to do good for us.
He wants to please us and he wants us to
rejoice in the fact that we trust him to
do for us that which we ask for. H that
is a wonderful experience to trust in
the Lord no matter what and believe that
he's going to do what is best for each
and every one of us. anyone. Well, I
just want to reiterate for those of you
who are watching that uh we welcome your
um comeback or whatever, you know,
questions, but as far as if we're not
getting it the way you see it or
whatever, we welcome that too. We don't
look at ourselves as infallible. All
right? So, share with us. Amen. Just
want to thank you, Johnny, Daniel,
Shelly. Thank you, 3ABN family. Just
know how much we love you and appreciate
you. God bless you.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.